these tanks here in europe
a dog is more respectable when my
daughter camille dumas father brings me back in
circles
i don't know anything we
in league 2
i hope against the syrians but i am
against the german political system
models who argue
today with a friend a man the son
there are plans that came
straight in as if in turmoil and without coming
directly you have hashish from the
drop his life is hard the east m21 took the
laws are criminals
the marcels of rigor j  I'm trying to
integrate myself to do the ultras the desert
it seems to be from the state now
it's us who are running for integration
and the interrogation course we need to
be given a permit which should we
n  it's not
blind calls for a mac gala the
black refugees who are here in germany seem to
take all the refugees and they
would like you to invite them to make
the difference between us